you got to come out to my dealership and
see my dealerships do you have a car
dealership i own a harley-davidson
dealership are you serious yeah santa
clarita california it's not far
you need to come on out it's movie
posters it's all my memorabilia t2
arcade it's sort of my guys kind of go
like yeah we know who owns this place oh
i gotta go there for sure it's uh it's i
love harley davids harley davidson saved
my life man i mean it's it's why is that
uh literally i i uh
well
go ahead
in brief in brief oh i got started i got
stung by a bee riding a harley-davidson
i pulled over on the side of the road
because i felt like i was having a heart
attack and i didn't realize i was having
an anaphylactic reaction to this piece
i turned off the bike i was straddling
the bike i cast out went into an
anaphylactic
uh i think they call it a fever fever
whatever yeah so i went unconscious on
the bike straddling it with the
kickstand down but the bike i had shut
it off but the bike and the pipe was so
hot they woke you up it burned it burned
my leg
they say my adrenal gland reacted as a
result it was like getting an epipen
kicked me back up to life i pulled
myself away from the bike it was on
mulholland highway right across from
calabasas high school
and i passed out in the in the in the
bushes under the trees i can show you
the spot pretty much there it's right
it's right where i grew up actually so
so you know right across the street
under those trees and i'm under there
right at that
anyway
and i
pass out again and i wake up and um
i've pissed myself sure i'm soaking wet
i have [ __ ] and leaves all over me so
obviously i've been flopping around like
trying to
i fought it
and i rode home and went and saw my
doctor the next day and he said well
apparently you had an allergic reaction
to this piece thing it was on the side
of your head and you went into an
anaphylactic shock and let me see that
burn and you're lucky to be alive
wow